sociologiquement de choses très
intéressant aux états unis on aime ce
qui est exceptionnel des acteurs
exceptionnels brad pitt très beau ceux
qui sont inatteignables lui-même en
france on aime les gens comme nous
pardon même bien que les petits bouts de
chou chou ça mais c'est vrai les leaders
chez nous les mieux payés sont demandés
si chauvin peu gros et tlc prennent tout
le monde a des poches sous les yeux
maintenant la nuit mais c'est vrai
regardez regardez que jdd les acteurs
préparent donc admirable tout ça c'est
pas des cadres des critères de beauté
on aime bien ce qui est proche de nous
ce qu'ils nous ressemblent en france
etats unis on aime celle inverse qu on
ne peut pas atteindre alors hissé son
avis nord quand on arrive aux états unis
toutes les sitcoms met en scène des gens
résistent classe moyenne femme au foyer
mais freud des américains moyens humains
et du public américain s'y reconnaît et
c'est la même chose pour que nintendo ce
que tu viens de dire c'est faux de a
généré en amérique ne sont pas cette
tête non plus pas merci
souplesse heureusement que tu pourras
sur un poney l'héroïne de friends
oui ça j'espère à cosworth a rien su
muller meilleur si rose anne c'est brad
pitt qui débarque là c'est emilie le
mariage de diana quand twingo hier s'il
vous plaît les acteurs les mieux payés
en france et jean dujardin guillaume
canet tient bien que moi mais c'est tout
ce qui m'est arrivé cette semaine tu
fait d'être en mauvaise émission
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais non mais non mais là dessus là ils
pouvaient pas aller par les bêtises
c'est toi le talon c'est le truc excuse
moi la think city je veux dire dans
laquelle les français se reconnaissent
cependant sauf le jdd le top du jdd
pardon s'est jamais des canons de beauté
on a eu des caméras des polémistes est
ténue liège énormément j'étais maman oui
alors oui maintenant une exception dans
chaque émission mercer sinon mais pas
vous lâcher ses six essais ce qui
t'arrive là qu'il ya un problème on suit
la fatwa la la vigile armé
j'ai marché nerveux aussi attention
privé après avoir perdu tes je perds pas
ton vif la mode et n'importe quoi sur
les gros chiffres de cette série tant
pis je ne dirai rien c'est pas si vous
allez dire alors géraldine maillet qui
parle justement en entraînant après
l'histoire non il dit n'importe quoi
mais bien sûr on va savoir que ce n'est
rien au cinéma mais j'invite tout le
temps brad pitt brad pitt bras des
bombes a bien fonctionné mais n'a jamais
joué dans donc la police et il a fait un
gars vue d'un accord c'est maïs et riz
récurrent chez tous les acteurs les gary
oldman et kevin ce maïs et tout ça
excuse moi c'est des mecs de série qui
sont très moche et même pour lui
série mais aussi de capitelles marleau l
extraordinaire parce que c'est une sorte
de colombo en chapka très très fort
c'est qu'elle était roi est allé à
l'autre chose que de l'emmo est un
système mais c'est dans l'air du temps
en fait c'est un fils gilet jaune